hey guys it's max in this video I want
to see if the MacBook Air overheating is
overblown now you guys probably saw my
previous videos all the excitement I had
with these new MacBook Airs the
quad-core processor for just a hundred
dollars more which led into me kind of
not recommending that anymore because of
the laptop getting too hot
constantly running at 100 degrees
Celsius even when you're not pushing it
that far and the worst thing of all not
just items but the noise that comes with
it now I recently watched a video by the
one in only and he did a comparison
between the old gen MacBook Air the i3
model that I now recommend in the i-5
model that I personally purchased and
his results kind of showed that it
didn't get that hot not like some of my
tests so in this video I just want to
clarify some of my findings and why some
of his were different and then give you
guys my final opinion and see how kind
of we differ with him and also how some
of our findings still match up and are
valid so let's go ahead and get started
here as you guys can see this MacBook
Air is running at 37 degrees Celsius the
fan is off this thing was sitting here
overnight and let's go ahead and do a
few tests I'm gonna go ahead and open up
Safari and a lot of these tests here an
Safari so let's go ahead and open up
YouTube and I just want to explain why
we're getting some differences so right
there we opened it up hit 60 degrees
Celsius not an issue and then let's go
ahead and open up say a YouTube video
let me go ahead and maybe scroll down
over here stuff is loading up everything
looks fairly good we're watching a great
mkbhd video 1080p 30fps no problems our
temps are lining up we're getting closer
to 60 right here and let's go and open
up let's say a 4k 30 video which he also
showed off and there we shouldn't have
any issues whatsoever now let's see what
our temps do here we're running at 57 55
this is running great let's go ahead and
open up just a few more tabs just like
he did now we're running at 79 let's
flip over here 74 this is normal use and
as I said in my video
I would HIGHLY highly recommend running
Safari it is much more efficient in our
temps are lower now wit Safari it runs
great and with 30 FPS videos it also
runs pretty good let's go ahead and open
up a 1080p 60 video over here and now
we're at 81 degrees Celsius the fans are
running at 2779 just like you showed off
I have a couple tabs open this is still
normal use and it's working just fine
now one thing in my videos I'm gonna go
ahead and quit that up open up Chrome I
started off with Chrome and I was also
playing back just 60fps not 30 so let's
go and hit YouTube and I'll show you
guys just how some of these apps that a
lot of people use are much less
efficient we just had 97 degrees Celsius
there I'm going to open up this top
video here
now we're 96 Celsius again 94 and this
is 1440 feet let's go ahead and go up to
4k 60 now I personally love playing back
4k videos the detail is really good even
if you don't have a 1080p display and
here just like I showed off to you guys
before if you guys can see we're running
at a hundred degrees Celsius 3100 rpm
now this might not be the normal use
case that most people would use it but
this is valid results for the system and
my biggest complaint wasn't that you
know in some cases it runs hot my
complaint was that Apple could have done
a much better job you guys know that we
are fans of mac books or fans of Apple
but when they do something wrong I don't
want to just excuse it and say hey
that's okay most people that buy this
system you know they're not gonna push
it that hard I want them to do better
especially when of its if it's something
that is so simple so here are still
running at 100 B Celsius 3100 rpms we're
getting some stuttering here and the
stuttering is because the system is
actually slowing down in throttling my
recommendation was for people to buy the
i3 processor and the one-and-only he did
a great job in his video I'll link it
down in the video description he said
that hey that processor the i-5 still
gets about 20 25 percent more
performance when we benchmark it and
because of that it's still worth getting
it you want a future-proof your MacBook
Air my opinion is if you're getting more
perform
to future-proof it and in the future
when you need the extra performance your
result is going to be a system running
super hot and then after a bit it's
gonna heat up and it's gonna run loud
what's the point of future proofing it
that way it's just gonna get annoying
later and let me show you guys another
example here at the games this is one of
my biggest issues where this whole thing
jumped out at me so we just started
updating for tonight right here the
download speed is very slow it's not
unpacking the data that quickly as
quickly as it could and that does make
the system heat up more just because our
internet slower here at the office but
we see our fans are running out 40 400
and after about a minute here it's gonna
ramp up to 8,000 so here you go after
just a bit we're already at over 6,000
rpm 6250 it's gonna keep ramping up and
the problem is this is not normal I mean
it's not only Epic Games
I've run other fairly basic tests not 4k
raw video editing stuff like that and it
gets heat soak the system does and then
just runs loud and hot and then that
four core slows down and it runs slower
than other Macs that have less power and
that's my biggest complaint and when we
go to Mac's fans I'll just click it
Mac's out maybe about after 30 seconds
but I'll click it it can't heat down the
system because that fan is not connected
to the heatsink
to the actual CPU it it doesn't
effectively cool it down so it just gets
hotter and harder and hotter and then
sits there now the fix there's a couple
of ways to fix I made a separate video
you guys can check that out after this
one basically it's not allowing the CPU
to have to heat up and then throttle
it's just slowing it down ahead of time
in your actual results in your you know
how fast stuff happens and how smooth
the system is it actually runs smoother
then allowing it to heat up all the way
and then be limited so here we're maxing
out the fan it's not gonna get any
cooler at all I'm gonna go back to
system it's gonna go to C 7000 right now
and this is my complaint I have to get
Apple about this I can't just say hey
you know people are gonna buy the system
they're not gonna push it that hard it's
just it's not good for them to have a
loud system when this could have been
avoided very easily and same thing if
you're just running Chrome
if you're running some Word documents
Excel sheets even basic stuff once the
system heats up now in his video he
played back 1080p 30 he played back 4k
30 he added different tabs on top of
each other and in the background Mac OS
does a great job so it's not taking up a
lot of resources and same thing with
Apple TV when he played that back Apple
TV will give you a 1080p 30 frames per
second video signal it's a very
efficient Apple does a great job with
their own programs but my complaint is
that people are gonna have a louder
system than they should a hotter system
than they could have had and the
performance is much less than it could
have been with a simple heat pipe so my
kind of conclusion is does the system
have a heat issue especially the i-5 yes
it does
I think the i3 just like the one and
only found a baby about 5 to 10 even 15
degrees cooler in some instances and
after you're using it for a half-hour in
an hour when the system is heat so even
after doing basic tasks that heat just
adds on I would just suggest just go for
the i3 and have less heat issues and
less fan noise issues that extras 20% of
performance isn't worth it when you get
it to deal with that so that's is my
opinion you guys let me know your
thoughts down in the comments section
below a B and H right now they're doing
100 bucks off the base model and that is
such an excellent deal for a brand new
MacBook Air with an excellent keyboard
and all the other updates that they made
thank you guys for watching there's been
max if you guys want to see more videos
you guys can click that circle above and
check out my other MacBook Air videos
right over there and I'll see you in the
next video
[Music]